that colorectal innit no it's worse I
love how we're like aficionados Somali
A's
okay luncheon meats hey I am CT I have a
plate of meat here and that's tight
because I love salami hi I'm Eli and boy
do I love those sweet deli meats I'm
Jake I have a brilliant relationship
with deli meats
I am Josh and I am a sandwich aficionado
I love a good sandwich a sandwich a hero
a grinder a wedge
well I'm a big I was always grew up as a
big hand boy know why hams always wet
I'm still gonna go for the the hard
salon because I want that salt usually
people like cheers in one of these I
don't think we're doing that today yeah
nice wet I mean deli meat is already
disgusting looking if you look at it and
this is pretty low-rent maybe there's a
little paprika in there I know what
you're trying to do here and it's not
gonna work you're not gonna break me
deli meats are primarily made from the
leftover trimmings from other meat
products along with several additives
okay all right so our chicken nuggets
our forefathers ate everything from
snout to tail hey science thank you for
making all those oh the butts and the
noses taste good in April of this year
the CDC reported a listeria outbreak
linked to deli meat that made eight
people sick and resulted in one death
those are good odds yeah the meats and
cheeses that caused the outbreak came
from different brands as well as
different delis across several states
it usually takes one to four weeks but
may take as long as 70 days for the
symptoms of an invasive listeriosis to
show up yeah sounds like a bad disease
sounds like a Harry Potter spell
listener else's listeriosis it was
pooping in the food like
we need to figure out well would you do
if you had 70 days left go take a
vacation we're gonna go maybe Big Sur
yeah I hear it's beautiful there yeah
a 2010 Harvard University study included
that eating processed deli meats can
increase the risk of heart disease by
42% 42% sky-high yeah yeah sure
smoking like french fries and like Oreos
and like a anything good very talked
about however yet everything kills you
raisins probably make you die down here
it's killing you the same study also
linked processed meats with a 19 percent
higher risk of developing type 2
diabetes I already have the meat sweats
alright 22 scientists working in
conjunction with the World Health
Organization found that eating processed
meats regularly increases one's risk of
cancer the 2015 study noted those who
eat one point eight ounces of processed
meats per day have an 18% higher risk of
colorectal cancer which is a bad one the
blood cancer yeah okay yep oh man that
just sounds bad that wasn't Listeria
girl rectal not here for it there's some
really bummer words in these is there a
little tag line that says hey this gives
you only 2% cancer instead of like 8%
cancer according to the American
Institute for cancer research Luke
cancer even just 15 grams of processed
meat for a day the equivalent of one
slice of deli Hannah increases the risk
of colorectal cancer by four percent
thank you there's that word again
oh you're pushing me in the corner with
everything starts at zero right yes if
it increases by four percent for every
slice I think just during college I
increased my cancer percentage by like
20 thousand percent sodium nitrates or
nitrates have typically been used to
help preserve deli meats provide a
certain taste and protect against
botulism
but these additives may also be
responsible for the growth of
cancer-causing compounds once we've
eaten them
hmm cancer me this is cancer me and you
can get nitrate-free
deadly products how is this legal
nitrate free these preservatives keep
the foods last longer but they're
essentially killing you you solve the
world's problems right there do you want
to like you know die of food poisoning
or do you want this I'm the president of
the World Health Association that's
someone it's called large salami or
Bologna typically use beef bung casings
which are made from the part of a cow's
large intestine extending to its colon
or anal opening well that's what a
that's what a large intestine does
getting getting the most out of it
it's a bummer when you think about it
man it's a bummer I just really want to
say eating but is getting popular so bad
how bad is it gonna read this and then
I'll try to act out what these guys are
ways to tell whether your lunch meat has
gone bad include a foul smell
including vinegar or ammonia sense
smells like honey
okay that's good it's good if it's slimy
or sticky or seems to be covered in a
hell
that's so subjective like it is slimy
and sticky a change in color to yellow
brown green and pale gray this is good
it's like a pink like a light
it's a pinkish ink if you have a passion
for Delic meets you never gets to this
point like why does it smell like
ammonia why is it covered in a film
Oh what's the worst thing that's ever
happened to me not gonna eat any more of
this knees because you ruined it
I'm gonna be honest I didn't heal my me
you did what you set out to do and make
traximus ham we're not listening the
fact that I have to pay more to have
non-cancerous meat is disappointing I
feel the same way I think that I always
felt there's a few things in life that
you spend a lot of money on your
haircuts issues your suits and your deli
meats so I hope that people will see
this video and get an idea of what's
invest in and fortunately the world we
live in but if there's one thing to
invest in is nitrate-free but holding
hands are free deli meats it's all again
I kill me
it just might as well taste good
[Music]